they will face an opener in david phelps
yeah david phelps gets the open tonight
for the blue jays tj zoick will follow
phelps to the mound
breaking ball chopper hit towards shore
two hops for beshet in time one away
breaking ball swinging a miss and ohtani
strikes out two away soft stuff away and
if you watch that front side of ohtani
watch it leak out just a little bit too
much if you can keep that cutter slider
change up away from him the hips open up
just a little bit too quickly and that
results in another strikeout two and two
inside quarter strike three rendon is
called
on june the fifth that talented
left-hander will celebrate his 30th
birthday andrew heaney
goes to work he was a floridian early on
in his career as a marlins first round
pick out of oklahoma state
[Applause]
boy what a breaking ball right over the
top of it and down he goes that's that
back foot slider
pounding the right-handers on that
inside part of the plate
there's a pitch lifted in the air and
it's hit pretty well into right center
but hanging up and there to make the
catch on it is dexter fowler three two
two outs there goes beshet ball four
inside
so a two out single and a two out walk
and abujas are threatening here in the
bottom of the first
change up down and away change up away
fastball in as jose pointed out change
up back away we'll keep an eye on this
throughout the evening the bulk pitcher
tj zoick and zwick will come out of the
bullpen
they're swinging a miss a breaking ball
and upton strikes up
here's the 3-1 pitch and that is low and
he walks him
so the angels have him everywhere with
two outs a guy who kind of has a flare
for these situations will be batting and
that's david fletcher angel's base is
full
bouncing ball left side couple of steps
to his right not in time i hope dexter's
okay he slid hard in the base
and certified athletic trainer let's see
what we can see it's a slight bobble and
a quick hard throw but fowler going
quickly into the base
well i don't know if he ever slid right
i mean did he roll an ankle we got a
chance to look at the replay he never
slit at all right he's momentum he used
the bag to stop his momentum so he went
in there with that left foot so they did
get fowler up they have them on the
golf cart they never put him on a
stretcher or anything like that he now
will be
carded off and now the batter for the
angels will be shohei ohtani so very
strong
[Applause]
keeps his hands back hits a high fly
ball well struck to right field up
nearly out of here high off that wall
one
two
three angels will score
technically that man was just fooled by
the pitch and still he nearly hit it out
louis scurliel jr is out of the game you
could see him jogging down to the
clubhouse
lourdes gurillo jr left the game with a
reaction from his vaccination
into center field drifting back
mike trout all to right-handed batters
let that pitch travel drives it to right
field mr rojas again with another
opportunity interesting is it mike trout
allowed jose rojas to make the play on
it allowed him to get comfortable and
going to that angle and he runs it down
tripping at you great change out by team
dog on that one one two three inning
first matter up for the angels as we get
things going here in the top of the
fifth inning is shohei ohtani who drives
a ball deep out there near center field
and it's out of here
oh tony has homered
and he's putting on a pretty good show
tonight
shohei's third home run of the season
he's had a five we'll make it a four rbi
night tonight and the angels are up five
nothing two balls and no strikes to
count here on jared walsh he's had a
single and a walk in this ball game
oh my goodness crush to deep right field
off the batting cage roof
goodbye
a couple home runs in this inning
walsh continues to crush it third home
run of the season now nine rbis and
rohini has shut out the blue jays on
just one hit
like that
boom outside corner 92 miles an hour
though he didn't at all split the plate
that was a gorgeous pitch especially
with two strikes and 36 strikeouts with
it snuck right by him look at this
backhanded effort by fletcher
unbelievable he knew he had a runner he
could handle that takes nothing away
from the ground that david fletcher just
covered he gets by heaney and the
backhand he's in the outfield grass gets
very quickly into one hot throw to
washington they manage just a single hit
off andrew heaney that was in the first
inning he did
he literally dealt with all four corners
of that strike zone yeah i mean that's
that's pitching
beau comes up empty
that's nine strikeouts oh max dassey did
a fabulous job there i think beau buchet
was thinking change up there
we'll see
because that's a high pop-up that's an
easy chance mike trout
puts that one away a couple of base
runners on the inning that man
outstanding tonight we'll see if he
crosses the finish line
one two ground ball up the middle
it's gonna be trouble no play for
fletcher and simeon has his second hit
of the ball game
ground ball fair pass rendu down the
left field line
simeon is around second he'll stop at
third as randall grichik
sneaks a double past ren dune
for grichik that's his second double of
the season his first hit of the night
the dude
that one gets away from stasi here comes
simeon and he's going to score blue jays
are on the board
that was the evolution of the arm
breaking ball rolled to david fletcher
turned into and out
chris rodriguez might be back out to
lock this one up
[Music]
relax yourself and finish off this
batter with the nasty curveball
the 2-2
breaking ball popped up
and enjoy playing for the angels chris
because your team eight games in
is six and two
what a dynamic start for this team in
2021 and they're victorious by a score
of seven to one over the blue jays well
balanced again great starting pitching
from andrew heaney solid bullpen works
of defense but the balance in the lineup
for joe madden's club showway ohtani
what a game